Okay. So I deleted my old tickets sold field.
>> Yep.
>> And remember when we went to the festival, and there
were all those people outside like, get your tickets, get your tickets.
>> I think they had a sketchier voice than that. Like, you need some tickets?
>> Get your tickets, yeah.
>>
[LAUGH]
>> Okay, totally sketchy, I don't want these scalpers at
my festival. the reason this stuff always happens is because
You know, one person could buy like a thousand tickets
and then they can sell them at like 10X value.
>> Yeah.
>> Which is super-annoying. so, so how can I, say,
for example, don't let anyone buy more than one tickets?
>> So that's really easy to do in Salesforce, because
you can just create a rule that prevents that from happening.
And what that is called in Salesforce is a Validation Rule.
>> Okay.
>> And so basically you set up some
sort of condition that shouldn't happen, and if
it does, it throws an error at whoever's
you know, trying to create or modify the record.
>> Okay, let me try and do this. So this is on
attendees, because we don't want the attendee to buy more than eight tickets.
>> Exactly.
>> And I'm going to click my little friend on the right.
Oh, okay, a few validation rules. Add one.
>> Yep.
>> Okay, let me give this a shot and tell me if I make any mistakes.
>> Alright.